madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal le 50e anniversaire de l'otan
avec l'ouverture à washington du sommet
de l'alliance première décision
la poursuite des frappes aériennes et le
rejet catégorique de la proposition du
président serbe sur une présence
internationale au kosovo le temps qu'ils
décident l'embargo sur le pétrole à
destination de la yougoslavie et du
monténégro alors que sur place au lieu
de la vie les opérations militaires se
poursuivent
plusieurs explosions à pristina en fin
de journée et hier soir la télévision
serbe a été prise pour cible
air france reconduction alice de la
grève des personnels au sol 9e jour du
mouvement des perturbations dans le
trafic
le centenaire du musée océanographique
de monaco le prince rainier célébrera
dimanche cet anniversaire un million de
visiteurs chaque année pour l'un des
plus grands aquariums du monde
il ya donc quelques heures à peine
s'ouvrait aux états unis le sommet du
cinquantenaire de l'otan le sommet de
washington qui s'est transformée en un
véritable conseil de guerre
l'heure n'était plus aux festivités on a
prié les délégations de laisser leurs
smokings vestiaires parmi les premières
décisions prises l'intensification des
frappes aériennes et le rejet unanime de
la proposition plus que confuse du
président serbe figaro
l'image qui restera du 50e anniversaire
de l'otan est sans aucun doute cette
photo de famille qui symbolise aussi
l'ouverture des travaux
on se souviendra qu'elle coïncide
exactement avec un mois de bombardements
sur la yougoslavie
pour préparer cette rencontre trois
heures d'un véritable conseil de guerre
auront été nécessaires les trois
nouveaux membres de l'organisation ont
été salués avec une chaleur particulière
c'est bill clinton qui a tenu à rappeler
l'enjeu du dispositif militaire braqués
sur le kosovo d'aujourd'hui nous
envoyons un message clair d'unités de
détermination de soutien aux raids
aériens qui continueront aussi longtemps
qu'il le faut un message de fermeté sur
les conditions qui permettront l'arrêt
des bombardements
la france qui n'écarte aucune
possibilité de solution considère
cependant que la proposition de belgrade
rapportés par victor tchernomirdine à
savoir l'interposition de civils au
kosovo est loin de faire la mesure ce
que lui a dit il
je milosevic et
et tout à fait insuffisant
je ne nie pas du tout que ce soit
inutile dit que ça ne correspond pas aux
exigences de la communauté
internationale telles qu'elles ont été
notamment exprimée par le secrétaire
général de l'onu
l'amérique aujourd'hui a pris le relais
géographique de l'europe
c'est ici que va se conduire la guerre
pendant trois jours la capitale fédérale
se donne des allures de camp retranché
les fonctionnaires ont été mis en congés
les rues du centre ville sont interdites
les contrôles sont partout la crainte
d'un attentat est palpable
l'amérique ne laisse rien au hasard
d'autant qu'il y va de sa crédibilité et
tout au long de cette journée d
information multiples et contradictoires
sur le résultat de la visite de
l'émissaire russe hier à belgrade
la confusion des communiqué nathalie
moisins bien sûr de lui victor
tchernomirdine lorsqu'il vient faire
devant les caméras le compte rendu de sa
mission diplomatique à belgrade
l'émissaire de boris eltsine pour la
yougoslavie vient de rentrer à moscou
il assure alors qu un progrès important
en direction de la paix vient d'être
accompli la yougoslavie a accepté la
présence de représentants d'autres pays
bien sûr militaire évidemment avec
l'accord de la yougoslavie
néanmoins il nous faut maintenant
travailler avec les représentants de
l'otan c'est au terme de huit heures de
discussions avec slobodan milosevic que
victor tchernomirdine aurait obtenu
cette importante concession mais très
rapidement une alternance de communiqués
contradictoires vient briser le bel
optimisme de moscou la yougoslavie
dément les affirmations russe elle
n'accède au kosovo qu'un déploiement
d'observateurs civils des nations unies
cette fois nous avons discuté des
modalités différentes
une présence de l'onu non armée
d'observateurs au kosovo dans la soirée
bill clinton avait d'ailleurs accueilli
prudemment les premiers résultats de la
mission russe
c'est la première fois que monsieur
milosevic le rsa représente je suppose
un pas en avant
ma préférence va à une solution qui
rencontreraient l'accord de toutes les
parties en présence
le premier ministre britannique se
montrait lui encore plus catégorique
ce n'est pas suffisant car cette
proposition ne satisfait pas les
conditions que l'otan a posé l'espoir
soulevé par la médiation russe n'aura
donc duré qu'un temps
de son côté le secrétaire général des
nations unies doit se rendre la semaine
prochaine à moscou at il annoncé au
terme d'un entretien avec le président
du conseil italien
nous allons maintenant rejoindre à
moscou et à washington aux deux
correspondants pour tenter de mieux
comprendre cette guerre des communiqués
alors d'abord gilles rabin à moscou
comment doit-on décoder ce qui peut
apparaître de plus en plus commun un
cafouillage diplomatique au ce qui
apparaît ce soir à moscou où béatrice
comme l'un des plus étonnantes
cafouillages de la récente histoire de
la diplomatie mondiale
la journée en effet vu tomber pas moins
de sept démentis successifs
chaque démenti démentant bien sûr le
démenti précédent le dernier est
particulièrement cinglant pour victor
tchernomirdine qui croyait avoir obtenu
hier de belgrade
l'accord sur eux un accord sur une force
d'interposition de sécurisation
internationale au kosovo
ce dernier démenti émane tout simplement
du ministre des affaires du gotha des
affaires étrangères lui même qu'il est
car nous n'avons pas abordé cette
question alors béatrice on apprendra
peut-être un jour les secrets et
quelques-uns des mensonges de ce faux
l'épisode mais ce qu'on peut dire déjà
ce soir c'est que moscou vient d'essuyer
un nouvel échec à belgrade
et on peut aussi émettre quelques doutes
sur la capacité de monsieur
tchernomirdine à relancer ou même tout
simplement à poursuivre sa médiation
entre la yougoslavie et l'otan merci
gilles rejoignant tout de suite alors à
washington laurent boussier en tout cas
aucune équivoque possible pour
l'alliance la proposition du président
serbe est définitivement à rejeter
oui vous l'avez compris la proposition
faite par les russes et par les serbes
est très en dessous du minimum que peut
accepter l'otan pourra arrêter ces
frappes de toute façon la première de
ces conditions c'est le retrait des
forces serbes du kosovo et pour
l'instant il n'en est pas question
de toute façon pour les responsables de
l'alliance il cette proposition non
seulement débat clair mais elle
elle même ce que ne veulent pas les
responsables de l'alliance et revenir à
la situation qui prévalait avant ses
frappes c'est à dire des observateurs de
l'osce et non armés empêcher de faire
leur mission et puis bon il est évident
que les réfugiés du kosovo qui ont fui
le kosovo ne reviendront pas s'ils
reviennent un jour sans une forte
présence militaire occidentale au kosovo
dans quelques instants devrait se
dérouler à washington d'une conférence
de presse qui fera le point sur ce mini
sommet qui vient donc de s'achever
attend davantage d'informations sur ce
qui s'est dit lors de ce qui apparaît
être un conseil de guerre il y a eu deux
ont deux choses ont été abordés pendant
ce sommet la première c'est la poursuite
de ces frappes je dirais faute de mieux
et leur intensification on va taper un
peu plus fort et sans limite de durée
il ya aussi cet embargo pour la première
fois et ça c'est une nouvelle l'otan
parle d'un embargo sur les produits
pétroliers sur la serbie on a évoqué
aussi un petit peu
l'intervention terrestre mais de manière
marginale et puis le deuxième suivi de
sujet de conversation des dix-neuf chefs
d'état des pays de l'alliance ça a été
la déstabilisation régionale c'est une
crainte les pays qui entourent la
yougoslavie et les sept pays qui
entourent la yougoslavie subissent plus
ou moins cette crise et on va essayer
maintenant de les aider de les rassurer
en leur proposant des accords de défense
des accords de sécurité
vous le savez dimanche prochain il y à
une réunion où sont invités les chefs
d'état de ces pays l'otan réaffirmera
qu' aucune menace territoriales sur ces
pays n'est acceptable
merci laurent prévue de longue date
anniversaire du cinquantenaire de l'otan
devaient se dérouler à partir
d'aujourd'hui à washington en présence
des 19 membres de l'alliance et des 25e
pays partenaires le faste des cérémonies
n'est plus au programme créé en avril 49
à washington ce qui est devenu la plus
grande puissance militaire mondiale
affronte aujourd'hui une crise majeure
sans précédent qui pourrait mettre en
jeu sa survie et sa crédibilité gérard
grecque
en pleine guerre froide le 4 avril 1949
à washington est signé le traité de
l'atlantique nord
l'article 5 prévoit une riposte des
alliés et donc des américains à une
attaque étrangère contre l'un des douze
pays signataires
le blocus de berlin par les soviétiques
en 1950 la guerre de corée semblent
donner raison à ceux qui considèrent que
la troisième guerre mondiale est proche
l'alliance se dote d'une structure
politique et d'une structure militaire
en 1952 l'otan s'élargit à la grèce et à
la turquie puis trois ans plus tard à
l'allemagne de l'ouest
l'influencé américaine sur l'otan est
évidemment écrasante même si pour la
forme le secrétaire général qui a une
fonction politique est européen
le commandant suprême chef militaire lui
est toujours américain
chacun des deux camps l'otan comme le
pacte de varsovie masse des troupes en
europe et s'équipent d'armes nucléaires
tactiques c'est l' équilibre de la
terreur qui durera jusqu'à la chute du
mur de berlin
et paradoxalement permettra à l'europe
de vivre en paix en 1966 le général de
gaulle décide de retirer la france de la
structure militaire intégrée de l'otan
l'alliance transfère son siège en
belgique la france se dote de l'arme
nucléaire et refuse de partager ses
secrets militaires avec les états unis
mais qu'à l'expiration des engagements
que nous avons pris jadis cessera pour
ce qui nous concerne la subordination
qualifié d' intégration qui est prévu
par l'otan et qui remet notre destin
entre les mains étrangères
la france quitte la structure militaire
de l'otan mais pas l'alliance atlantique
la détente est wes ne viendra qu'au
milieu des années 80 au moment où miral
gorbatchev prend le pouvoir à moscou
lorsqu'en novembre 89 le mur de berlin
tombait que deux ans plus tard l'union
soviétique disparaît l'otan n'a plus
d'ennemis commence alors toute une
réflexion sur l'avenir de l'alliance
atlantique alors que trois anciens pays
socialistes la rejoigne la guerre froide
avait gelé tout antagonisme entre les
peuples après quarante ans de paix en
europe la guerre commence dans les
balkans elle dure depuis dix ans
l'otan bombarde la serbie depuis
hambourg au plan militaire la 30e minute
des opérations de l'alliance avec pour
cible une nouvelle fois la capitale
belgrade bombardé à la fois sa
périphérie est au coeur même de la ville
la télévision serbe symbole aux yeux de
la tante de propagande du pouvoir de
milosevic pulvérisé peu après deux
heures du matin sur l'écran à ce moment
précis slobodan milosevic
l'image c'est alors figé françois korber
2h06 la nuit dernière au centre de
belgrade une bombe guidée laser tira à 8
km de son objectif depuis une altitude
de 5 à 6000 met pour déjouer la des ca
vient de toucher sa cible que le pilote
de l'otan identifié auparavant sur
l'écran de son radar d'acquisition dix
morts et 18 blessés seront retirés des
décombres du bâtiment de la télévision
serbe
selon l' agence de presse hugo cela ben
thanh young une frappe qualifié de
légitime soit par l'alliance est
annoncée en filigrane depuis le 17 avril
par le général clark commandant les
forces alliées au motif que la
télévision serbe était un outil de
propagande du président milosevic
depuis ses studios de la rts étaient
diffusés comme vous allez le voir ce
genre de clip déplaisant fortement à
l'otan
si après la rts 70 personnes
journalistes présentateurs et
techniciens se trouvait dans les locaux
au moment du raid
le présentateur de la télévision serbe
lançait un entretien en différé accordée
par ce modèle milosevic hier à la
télévision américaine de houston avant
que l'image de ce fils ou tre siège de
la rts des relais de transmission harley
satellite est un émetteur de la
télévision serbe ont été détruits par
d'autres raids sur l'ensemble du
territoire du go slave
ce qui n'a pas empêché la rts de
reprendre ses émissions en début de
matinée à partir d'un autre studio de
télévision privée mais pour combien de
temps correspondance à belgrade de
jacques merlino grade laissant croire
que tout ce qui est télévision de petite
ou de grande taille sera bombardé ce qui
fait que toutes les sociétés concernées
sont en train de déménager et de
s'installer dans des abris alors que les
chasseurs bombardiers de l'otan viennent
de re décoller d'aviano pour une 31e
nuit de frappes belgrade pourrait bien
en effet subi d'autres bombardements
depuis plusieurs jours maintenant on
évoque l'hypothèse un embargo sur
l'approvisionnement de pétrole à la
république fédérale de yougoslavie
les quinze ont approuvé ce matin cette
interdiction est pour sa part le temps
vient de décider de l'embargo pétrolier
contre belgrade
étudiante au passage la possibilité d'un
blocus maritime pascal golomer 7 hier
que les membres de la commission
européenne ont mis la dernière main au
texte un texte approuvé dès aujourd'hui
par les quinze pays de l'union avant
même que les ministres des affaires
étrangères se réunissent à luxembourg
lundi l'union européenne interdira donc
à ses ressortissants de livrer tous
produits pétroliers à la république
fédérale de yougoslavie serbie et
monténégro ce pétrole arrive par bateau
en croatie avant d'être acheminés par
oléoducs dans la serbie un oléoduc qui
transporte également du pétrole venu de
russie via la hongrie mais le pétrole et
surtout livré directement dans le port
de bar au monténégro il ya quelques
jours
un navire français aurait accosté ici
avec 2600 tonnes de pétrole à bord
destinés à la compagnie pétrolière serbe
mais les quinze le savent pour que la
mesure soit efficace
ils doivent convaincre les pays voisins
de la serbie de lisibilité des pays qui
n'auront pas forcément le choix s'ils ne
se sentent pas contraint par cette
décision il le ils braveront l'hostilité
de l'union européenne les crédits de
l'union européenne qui leur sont
destinés seront probablement supprimer
ou suspendu et donc ça constitue pour
ces pays
une épée de damoclès qui veulent être
utilisé de façon très efficace pour
l'instant seule la hongrie a donné son
accord mais difficile pour ces pays
riverains de contrôler tous les
mouvements de camions aux frontières
tout va dépendre notamment dans cette
région de l'efficacité de contrôle de
ces états sur leurs frontières en
chantier fluvial terrestre et une sur le
contrôle notamment des groupes mafieux
et la criminalité organisée qui
utilisent le trafic des hydrocarbures la
france le dit depuis plusieurs jours il
est difficile de toute façon d'aller
au-delà jusqu'au blocus total de la
serbie par exemple faute d'une
résolution du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu
ce soir l'otan par le d'ailleurs
d'embargo sur les hydrocarbures mais
sans préciser les moyens pour y parvenir
au monténégro maintenant après la
manifestation qui réunissait hier près
de dix mille personnes venues soutenir
le président milosevic cette petite
république qui je vous le rappelle fait
partie de la fédération yougoslave est
de plus en plus déstabilisé nos envoyés
spéciaux
venez duquesne et jean françois renaud
podgorica n'a donc pas connu son grand
soir pas encore au réveil ce matin la
place étaient désertes et les
manifestants dispersés sans heurts mais
le hasard a voulu que le premier
ministre tienne à 11h une conférence de
presse
officiellement pour tirer le bilan d'un
mois de frappes aériennes
de fait pour répondre à l'appel lancé
par le leader de l'opposition proche de
milosevic
momir bullet witch qui demande que la
police monténégrine passe sous le
contrôle de l'armée fédérale
c'est un appel direct au conflit à la
confrontation entre ceux qui portent
l'uniforme de la police et ceux qui
portent celui de l'armée entre les
citoyens qui soutiennent l'armée ceux
qui sont derrière la police et ça ne
peuvent qu'aboutir à une catastrophe
pour le monténégro et c'est bien ce
qu'ont compris les habitants de
podgorica qu'ils le souhaitent ou qu il
le redoute
il a raison bulatovic il faut que ça
soit comme ça que la police obéissent à
l'armée ne peut pas contrôler notre
police c'est quelque chose qui nous
appartient c'est la seule chose qui nous
reste encore il faudrait que le
monténégro s'engagent davantage du côté
de la serbie
si on a plus la serbie on aura plus de
pas à manger c'est la bac sont toutes
les usines que l'otan essaye de détruire
tout comme les ponts les routes et
hôtels pour arriver au chaos
alors une fois de plus ce soir les
partisans de bullet witch se rassemblent
sur la place principale des
manifestations comme autant de coups de
boutoir dans l'espoir d' ébranler la
toute petite république monténégrin
et en direct de podgorica benoît
duquesne on l'a dit il ya quelques
instants le monténégro devrait subir
l'embargo sur le pétrole
une situation qui fragilise un peu plus
le pays absolument et cette décision
n'était pas encore connue ce matin lors
de la conférence de presse du premier
ministre qu'il évoquait déjà en
expliquant abondamment les conséquences
économiques que cela aurait pour la
république ici compris pour l'aide
humanitaire apportée aux réfugiés et en
proposant tout simplement et bien que le
monténégro soient exclus de cette cet
embargo autrement dit qu'on continue à
livrer du pétrole d'ici au monténégro et
en disant mais au besoin que l'onu
contrôle même que ce pétrole ne
repartent pas en serbie sans savoir très
bien comment on pourrait effectuer
effectivement ces contrôles une question
évidemment très importante ici vous
savez que la situation du monténégro est
très très fragile sur le plan politique
on l'a beaucoup dit on ressent chaque
fois qu'il ya des bombardements par
l'agressivité de la population ici
notamment à l'égard des journalistes
et puis aussi sur le plan économique
vous savez que cette république ni
quasiment exclusivement dépendante pour
ces échanges de la serbie que ces
échanges bien sûr depuis la guerre ont
quasiment cessé et qu'il que s'ajoute à
cela le poids aussi de la soif des 70
milles environ réfugiés que le mot
monténégro accueilli qu'il faut
supporter tout cela coûte de l'argent et
ce matin le premier ministre en appelait
tout simplement à l'aide internationale
merci benoît de ces précisions en
bulgarie au coeur même de la capitale
deux manifestations se sont déroulées ce
matin l'une anti otan rassemblant
quelques centaines de personnes comme
chaque jour depuis le début des frappes
à quelques pas de là séparés par un
cordon policier
des partisans de l'otan ont ouvert le
feu vers le parlement bulgare
trois mille personnes environ appelant à
la chute de milosevic
un cortège portant les drapeaux aux
couleurs du parti bulgare ou pouvoir
les responsables de l'ess et font état
aujourd'hui d' atrocités au kosovo d'une
ampleur que personne n'avait imaginé ce
rapport établi sur la base de
témoignages de quelques 250 réfugiés
évoquent des cas de viols de tortures et
de mutilation ces témoignages que relate
ces hommes et ces femmes font partie du
quotidien de ces médecins envoyés sur
place dans les camps macédoine et en
albanie
portrait de l'un de ses médecins du
monde qui est à pied d'oeuvre à craquer
ce depuis près d'un mois maintenant elle
dit son désespoir et sa colère devant
l'ampleur de la tâche
une journée particulière que nous relate
claude sans pères et leurs numéros
c'est son dernier jour à couquèques
depuis la plus des premiers réfugiés
anne marie guillot travail dans cette
ville avec une quinzaine de volontaires
de médecins du monde
sa mission s'achève elle va être relevé
par un autre médecin bénévole c'est sa
dernière visite dans un des nombreux
camps improvisés de cocker l'heure des
adieux avec quelques réfugiés qui ont
travaillé avec elle pendant près d'un
mois garde des souvenirs d'une mission
vraiment merveilleuse mais triste et
très dur où vivent les enfants
pleuraient les mamans se sont jetés dans
nos bras et les gens nous en raconter
des choses crime les je crois c'est très
dur dans cette mission c'est quand on
s'identifie complètement aux gens quoi
repose avant de partir
un mari effectue un dernier tour dans le
coin il lui dit lui polique sûr qu'un
jour elle rentrera chez elle
j'espère si dieu le veut
mes quatre filles sont restés là-bas la
guerre on a laissé un mot bien nos
maisons brûlées mais ce qui
m'intéressait mais fils mes quatre fils
si dieu le veut
quelques mètres plus loin alors que la
pluie redouble un harry découvre un
nouveau groupe de réfugiés arrivés hier
soir une dame de 81 ans qui a passé la
nuit dehors dans le froid et à l'arrière
de la carriole une femme avec ses six
enfants qui va s'occuper de ce genre
pourquoi ils sont encore là lhc enfin
les informations qu'on a ce matin c'est
qu'ils veulent vider tous les camps
c'est ce que cette zone est une zone à
risque et donc apparemment il faut faire
partir tous les genres le problème c'est
que ces gens qui sont là qui ne vont pas
dans les camps parce que lyon
détracteurs et les tracteurs c'est leur
maison tout dans leurs tracteurs et donc
je crois qu'ils vont être obligés
d'abandonner leurs tracteurs pour partir
mais c'est une décision de la ménagère
qu'on comprend aussi à c'est une zone
qui seront pas trop saturé parce qu'on
est vraiment très très bas francs sur go
on et soigne mais nous on peut pas enfin
il faut il faut des abris qu'on peut pas
laisser regarder
regardez ses enfants tout à l'heure il
pleuvait des cordes et c'était sous la
flotte c'est pas possible le plus petit
à six mois le plus grand 9 ans
ces enfants avec leur mère ont fui leurs
villages près de mitrovica au kosovo
avant de repartir en france un à redone
les derniers conseils à l'équipe qui
reste ce soir toute la petite famille de
mitrovica va dormir à l'abri dès lundi
prochain anne marie elle retrouvera ses
collègues à l'hôpital d'angers
et puis quelques 850 albanais du kosovo
sont arrivés à pied hier soir après plus
d'une semaine d'errance harassés de
fatigue
partons maintenant plus au sud là où des
camps d'accueil se mettent en place pour
tenter de résorber le flot massif des
réfugiés au brier de l'air et patrick
voix se sont rendus dans l'un des camps
les plus importants de cette région de
du res constatant la précarité totale de
ces centaines de familles qui attendent
désespérément de repartir le bleu
presque incongru ici de 70 permet de le
repérer de loin
coincé entre une ancienne usine de
produits chimiques et une décharge
d'ordures le camp de chepy talent n'a
cessé de s'agrandir depuis trois
semaines les réfugiés qui offre le
visage désormais familier du malheur
continuent d'arriver
on les attendait du nord transférés des
camps bondés de conquête ils ont en fait
fi le monténégro où la situation est
aujourd'hui imprévisible
hagard soumis aux rigueurs de l'exil ils
rejoignent le connaissant déjà d'un
autre camp d'une autre ville le chemin
des tentes ou six cliniques ont exploité
on n'a pas eu le choix nous dit cette
femme on survit comme on peut les serbes
nous ont chassés
je ne sais même pas ce que mon fils est
devenu j'ai dû le laisser la barre du
derrière moi au kosovo 2002 sont
réfugiés sont regroupés ici
prévu pour 18 mille personnes le camp de
chipie talent et déjà la limite de la
saturation
le terrain offert par l'état albanais
vaste c'est vrai mais le sol de glaise
ne permet d'espérer aucun confort même
relatif il unique source à proximité
n'est pas potable
on se demande alors comment va
s'organiser l'installation des dizaines
de milliers de réfugiés qui s'amassent
dans le nord les grandes quand deux cent
mille les compagnies qu'on a vu dans des
dans des coins comme le zaïre et
compagnie cc absolument fou ça c'est mon
opinion personnelle qui n'engage que moi
mais c'est dingue de faire des camps de
sans milou de ou de 20me ou de 30000
personnes sacrées les problèmes sociaux
ça de fait crée des problèmes de vie
commune ça crée des problèmes de
logistique de contrôle de caen
puis de vie sociale aussi ils sont
officiellement 350000 entassés dans ces
immenses champs de boue que sont les
camps d'albanie et quel que soit
l'espoir irraisonnée qui fait encore
tenir ces réfugiés
on sent bien que les organisations
humanitaires s'organise pour gérer un
drame qui risque de durer
en france à présent après l'arrivée hier
de quelques 326 réfugiés nous avons
suivi un groupe de familles qui a été
installé au centre sonacotra de vernon
dans l'eure reportage sébastien legay et
bruno niver tout depuis son arrivée à
vernon la nuit dernière
ce qui prime c'est en fait
inlassablement le même dessein sa maison
qui a brûlé au kosovo à ses côtés dans
cette chambre du foyer sonacotra
caterina sa mère et a terminé sa soeur
commence à récupérer après l'exode le
voyage en avion et en quarts la famille
prend ses repères et pense déjà à
l'avenir proche
une des désirs particuliers peut te
connaître la vie nnent l'histoire de la
ville est content ça marche pas de
prendre d'avoir plus souvent possible
des contacts avec 1600 de lier des
amitiés commençons à s'intégrer et pas
penser à des atrocités convaincu qu'on
avait oublié tout ça
depuis ce matin les bénévoles des
associations caritatives
aidés par les résidents ne cesse
d'apporter des vêtements pendant ce
temps médecins assistantes sociales et
employés de la résidence recense les
besoins des réfugiés et organise leur
prise en charge qui rencontrent nos
familles il est souhaitable d'avoir des
chaussures ouvertes style sandalettes ou
tongs et des chaussons pour les enfants
ils sont arrivés hier je crois qu'on est
en en phase de repos d'ecoute diagnostic
et puis nous nous ouvrirons les espèces
un petit peu plus tard ouvrir les
espaces c'est d'abord faire connaître
vernon et ses habitants une visite est
prévue ce week-end c'est aussi leur
redonner confiance et un peu
d'indépendance
dès demain les réfugiés recevront de
l'argent 35 francs par adulte et par
jour 24 francs par enfant pour la
nourriture et les loisirs
la situation dans les balkans à
l'origine du plan vigipirate qui va être
renforcée dès demain en france qui va
être emporté de l'enfant c'est ce qu'a
annoncé jean pierre chevènement
précisant qu'il s'agit de prévenir tout
risque d'attentât
même si ce risque demeure faible
patrouillent dans les lieux publics
stations de métro les gares et aéroports
et puis affectation militaire devant des
sites sensibles aux états unis lyttelton
est toujours sous le choc après le
carnage dans un lycée de la ville
apparemment les deux adolescents qui se
sont suicidés avaient l'intention de
détruire l'établissement scolaire le
traumatisme de toute une population
reportage dominique derda quelques
larmes de cirer des flots de sanglots
lyttleton pleure ses morts
et pour longtemps encore l'amérique
s'interroge pourquoi pourquoi toute
cette haine pourquoi ici dans cette
banlieue que l'on disait paisible dans
cette école qui se voulait modèle ou
jamais jusqu'à ce 20 avril la violence
n'avait eu raison du dialogue
les deux jeunes meurtriers élèves de
terminale chacun les connaissais
personne n'imaginait qu'un jour ils
tueraient de sang froid
douze de ces collégiens et l'un de leurs
professeurs
à l'intérieur tout était dévasté les
explosions ont fait éclater les
conduites tout jeune et plafonds
l'éclairage tout pendait dans le fixe la
cafétaria été noyée sous une quinzaine
de centimètres dans les tables les
chaises étaient renversées les sacs des
enfants éparpillés partout des douilles
des bombes artisanales dans certains
n'avaient pas explosé
il y avait vraiment beaucoup de dégâts
et puis à laitages à la bibliothèque des
corsa et la mort the aussi les auteurs
du massacre on ne sait rien vraiment de
leurs motivations leurs familles ont
quitté leur maison dans un communiqué
elle dit chercher à comprendre une
pancarte seul témoignage de soutien leur
rappelle que des amis les aime et qu'ils
sont toujours là
l'église sur ses terres d'évangile garde
tout son pouvoir et l'on s'y pressent
avec la conviction d'être plus forts
ensemble avec l'espoir aussi de trouver
les mots qui combleront l'absence il
aimait tant joue au foot dans ma rue et
il aimait bien le baseball aussi et il
était tellement amoureux de moi
le rire c'est la vie qui reprend peu à
peu comme une revanche sur un destin si
cruel comme une résurrection la qualité
en france à l'aéroport de nice la grève
a été reconduite ce matin par les
personnels au sol d'air france
perturbations importantes dans le trafic
aérien
au neuvième jour de ce mouvement et
yasmina farber diane richard les
grévistes n'ont plus le droit d'occuper
les pistes du coup ils bloquent les
accès aux aérogares
une façon de dire leur mécontentement
après la rupture des négociations les
personnels au sol demande toujours la
suppression d'un plan qui prévoit de
céder certains services d'air france à
des sous traitants
lorsqu'on a demandé c'est que économie
et social doit au pouvoir se combiner
on va pouvoir avancer et si le dossier
où le volet social et papiers en compte
cette unité la discuter malgré la grève
et les bouchons certains passagers ont
pu embarquer sur des vols air france la
compagnie a repris un rythme de
croisière en assurant 70 % de son trafic
en nous faisant tout pour augmenter le
programme nous avons maintenant la
possibilité d'avoir accès aux avions et
puis aux installations ce qui nous
permet contenu de moyens de relancer un
programme substantiel au départ de nice
sans passer par les gus de toulon nous
avons connu précédemment
mais la concurrence reste vigilante pour
ce week-end cette semaine à waimes
acheminé au moins 2000 passagers d'air
france c'est le croisement de flux entre
la première semaine deuxième semaine de
vacances
donc on s'attend à beaucoup beaucoup de
passagers sur l'europe et vous avez mis
en place un dispositif particulier on a
rajouté trois vols jusqu'à présent et on
est prêt peut-être en mettre plus entre
nice et orly air france prévoit 10 vols
sur 17 pour ce week-end et la totalité
pour roissy les deux tiers des liaisons
transversales sont également maintenus
mais dans ce conflit les programmes
peuvent évoluer d'heure en heure
le crédit lyonnais annonce la vente de
l'immeuble parisien qui était le siège
de la compagnie pour un milliard et demi
de francs sur les quarante cinq mille
mètres carrés le fauve ryanair
continuera d'occuper le tiers de la
surface actualité sociale le plan social
de moulinex qui devrait supprimer près
de 200 emplois été suspendu par le
tribunal de grande instance de caen la
direction n'aurait pas respecté la
procédure de consultation des
représentants du personnel
et puis bm a annoncé aujourd'hui la
suppression de 1150 poste à corbeil
essonnes le groupe américain restructure
son usine en s'alliant à l'allemand
siemens
hier à toulon l'ex gendre de jean marie
le pen a été mise en examen et écrouée
dans la sphère des cantines scolaires
celui qui fut l'époux de marie caroline
le pen aurait servi d'intermédiaire
entre la municipalité la société de
restauration
plusieurs personnes sont déjà mises en
examen jean marie le pen s'étonne que
seul jean pierre gendron était incarcéré
à titre préventif
selon le président du front national
lisez caroff les cantines scolaires de
toulon c'est ce marché remporté en 97
par la société générale de restauration
qui vaut à l'ancien gendre de jean marie
le pen mise en examen depuis hier soir
jean pierre gendron dort en prison la
justice cherche à déterminer son rôle
exact dans l'attribution du marché
pour lui les problèmes commencent
l'année dernière avec une perquisition
de la mairie de toulon le juge tournier
en repart avec un fax à noter par jean
pierre gendron un fax destiné à la
société générale de restauration pour
laquelle ils travaillent et qui
dévoilerait les tarifs proposés par
reste un concurrent
peu après la ngr obtient le marché
normal elle a réussi à être la moins
chère
un marché suspect donc qui serait sans
doute passée inaperçue 107 sauveur
catalano et l'ancien patron du club de
foot de tout le monde devant un
magistrat
il a révélé l'existence d'une commission
de huit millions et demi de francs sur
le marché des cantines de l'argent que
la sgr lui aurait promis mais qui aurait
dit il était versée à la mairie et au
front national
cette dénonciation a déjà provoqué la
mise en examen de jean marie le
chevallier le maire et du député
socialiste robert gaïa pour délit
davantage la justice n'a pas pu pour
l'instant démontrer la corruption mais
avec la mise en examen de jean pierre
gendron
l'enquète pourrait remonter plus haut
voici le témoignage d'un conseiller
municipal fn présent lors de la réunion
d'attribution du marché avec lui il y
avait d'autres élus donc dit nash un
lâche et commencent à critiquer reste au
oui il sent pas sérieux tout ça je me
sur quatre roues tuait son chéri dans la
rage comme ça par les fonctionnaires et
puis je vous le flic de le pen il faut
voter pour la générale jean marie le pen
qui dans un communiqué s'étonne que seul
son ex gendre soit incarcéré dans cette
affaire il apparaît comme un lampiste
selon les propres termes du président du
front national du sport avec du tennis
l'open de monte-carlo en quarts dé
finale le dernier français en lice
jérôme golmard s'est qualifiée cet après
midi en battant l'espagnol carlos moya
tenant du titre et vainqueur du dernier
roland garros le français s'est imposé
face au deuxième joueur mondial 6 7 6 3
6 0 minute de jeu
et puis le monde du football français
celui de la télévision étaient réunis ce
matin pour assister aux obsèques de
notre confrère bernard père bernard
clerc est décédé la semaine dernière à
l'âge de 59 ans il avait débuté sa
carrière à la rtf en 63 avant d'intégrer
le service des sports
il avait notamment participé en 75 à la
création de stade 2 le renard père était
un éminent spécialiste du football mais
également du basket
il a été inhumé ce matin au cimetière
parisien de bagneux
le célèbre musée océanographique de
monaco fête ses 101 millions de
visiteurs chaque année un établissement
à la renommée mondiale pour le début du
troisième millénaire le grand public
aura l'impression d'aller lui même au
fond des mers gérard dalmas jean-marc
sur ça le palais de la mer s'est
accroché à son rocher célèbre et il ya
un siècle
tout juste
le musée océanographique de monaco est
l'oeuvre du prince albert 1er
il y à 80 ans ce précurseur de
l'écologie alerte et déjà le monde
scientifique sur les dégâts des
chalutiers racle en labourant les fonds
des océans 1901 le souverain navigateur
réussi sa pêche miraculeuse dit des
types inconnu par moins 6000 mètres
record qui tiendra un demi avant 1850
aucun savants ne s'intéresse aux
profondeurs albert 1er lui y croit et
crée le ses anneaux graphie et le public
mort tout de suite à cet univers
mystérieux il est vrai que les romans de
jules verne ont alors un énorme succès
extraordinaire grâce au procédé micro
aquarium la somptueuse salle de
conférences transmet le savoir sur
l'infiniment petit juste au-dessus de la
zone marrant vous voyez peut-être
quelque chose qui bouge
une sorte de tube avec des mouvements ça
c'est le coeur de la salle lunettes de
cinéma en relief et dans le grand public
plonge de son fauteuil dans le grand
bleu
l'aquarium la vitrine magique
les visiteurs en oublie la vitre qui les
sépare des milliers de pensionnaires et
dans la mer ou l'inquiétant poisson
pierre 18 épine mortels
l'hippocampe australien s'amuse à
ressembler aux kangourous et un autre
vie en tenue de camouflage en 2001 par
un système de dialogues vidéo direct
avec bateau et plongeurs les visiteurs
seront quasiment dans la mer l'aquarium
universel asie se termine cette édition
je vous en rappelle le principal titre
le 50e anniversaire de l'otan avec
l'ouverture à washington du sommet de l
alliance première décision
la poursuite des frappes aériennes et le
rejet catégorique de la proposition du
président serbe sur une présence
internationale au kosovo le temps qu'ils
décident l'embargo sur le pétrole à
destination de la yougoslavie et du
monténégro et puis jacques chirac qui
déclare à l'instant qu'il souhaite un
nouveau souffle pour l'alliance
atlantique
tout de suite la météo suivi du poids
rouste de valérie maurice 20h50 la
deuxième partie de l'ombre d'un doute
avec robin renucci minuit le dernier
journal laurence ostolaza demain 7h dans
thé ou café
catherine ceylac reçoit patrick dupont
sur le plaisir de retrouver demain 13h
je vous remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2
oh